foreign
well Jade we saw this headline earlier
this week from Yahoo and uh I'm curious
to get your thoughts on it here it is
half of Jen's ears said they don't see a
point in saving money until things
return to normal instead they're
investing in themselves George that
looks like you know I have thoughts on
this that's why I brought it to you Jade
so many thoughts so many questions so
little time number one the what the
whole part about until things return to
normal we talked about this a little
before the segment and I'm like are they
talking about the pandemic because the
pandemic is over
we need to Define normal
what is normal well normal is broke we
know that that's free okay but they're
wanting it like normal to them I think
is yeah everything's great the economy
is perfect I have a perfect job in the
perfect place and I can afford
everything I don't think that exists it
that is utopian it 100 does not exist
and let's look at it from this angle I
mean if you don't view times as normal
if you're still viewing times as you
know kind of like state of emergency or
like crazy inflation whatever that's the
best time to save right like that's when
we should be saving our money that's
when we should be pulling back a little
bit that's not really the time I don't
know I feel like the the thought here is
a little bit backwards for me but you
know maybe I'm not a gen zero so let's
say I'm missing something 56 of them put
their retirement planning on hold during
the pandemic which if you're in a time
where you're fearful I feel like saving
more money would be beneficial that's
what I'm saying you should be saving and
and more questions again more questions
Jen's ears so this is Young America I'm
thinking and here's my thoughts here
because I want people to retire and I
want them to invest in their retirement
early because we know that when it comes
to investing time is your friend right
but it's also making me wonder like what
you're investing already do you have
debt are you working the baby steps like
there's a way to do this and do it right
you know and they talk about here
they're prioritizing making up for those
missed years during the pandemic with
exciting experiences and good memories
George why are you provoking me George
I'm poking the bear here investing in
myself so what like starting my own
business again the the mentality here is
not making sense because on the one hand
we're like oh it's crazy times you know
we want to we don't want to save our
money like we want to wait till it goes
back to normal but on the other hand
we're talking about business ventures I
don't know there's just a side of this
that's not making a whole lot of sense
it feels like it's a good way to justify
doing whatever I want to do because
saving is like eating your vegetables
facts and so like hey it's not the time
to eat our vegetables people okay we're
in a time of Crisis yeah the Brussels
sprouts can wait yeah they're they're
this is like me time for these people
but these quotes are just their bed I
love that they're betting on themselves
we're investing in our cell is very Eat
Pray Love Like I'm gonna go find myself
in Europe and while I'm a big fan of
investing in yourself so that you can
have a better career if that means
furthering your education things like
that that's great yeah but we don't do
that at the expense of our financial
future definitely not and I mean I think
you can really have this pie in the sky
when it's comes to like betting on
yourself in business but I read a stat
that said 18 percent of startups fail in
the first year and 50 percent of
startups feel in five years so that's
that's risky like if we're saying I'm
gonna take my retirement money and bet
on myself now don't get me wrong I'm all
about like chasing a dream and like
going after stuff but we've we not at
the expense of like reality like we've
got to think this thing through there's
a right way to do this we want to set
ourselves up for Success right like
let's pay off our debt let's get some
great Savings in place you know let's
start saving up to to bet on yourself
but let's pay cash for it like let's not
go out and get like business loans and
no La Tida you know what I'm saying
there's a way to do this the financial
planner quoted in this said talking
about their clients said right now they
may be thinking I don't want to put
money into a retirement account because
that's taking away from the dollars that
I've been able to invest in myself and
what I'm trying to do to achieve my
dreams and create an impact for the
world LOL what in the We Are The World
Is this man mentality I don't know
George I I'm confused by it because
there was another part that said it said
um they are seeking some sort of control
because the Consumer Price Index it's
distressing stubborn inflation the stock
market volatility it says Americans are
facing Financial strain due to Rising
housing grocery costs it's also
difficult to put Faith in the stock
market which has seen significant ups
and downs they're literally bearing
their head under sand and going I'm just
going to go to the beach because life is
expensive well they're like the stock
market is going up and down I don't I
don't know what to do that is really the
heart of this is there is a microwave
mindset in our culture today we're not
thinking long term we see the stock
market go down and so they go well why
would I invest in that I'm just losing
money and the thing they need to
remember is and for you guys watching
the stock market does this but it does
this as it goes up so it goes up and
down while continuously traveling up so
we know that you know if you look at the
past okay we can look at the past 30
years and then S P 500 it's still having
an annualized rate of return 10.7
percent and we're going to look it up
this time in history 10 years from now
we're gonna go oh look at that little
dip you got to zoom out zoom out be a
crock pot in a world for full of
microwaves yeah invest into your future
regardless of what's happening in the
economy yes and you'll be far better off
but do it in the right way Jen's ears
let's get our debt paid off because I
know y'all got student loan debt oh yeah
they're trying to do 17 things at once
yeah you got to focus